[Upbeat funky techno]
- [Christian Pulisic:] The game was always my dream.
To play at the highest level,
to achieve greatness.
Too small. Not strong
enough. Won't make it.
You have to believe in
yourself when others don't.
Hard work, dedication,
and commitment
helped me to get to
this stage, to represent
my country at the biggest
tournament in the world.
Qualifying for this World
Cup, that was huge for me.
I've always wanted to
play in a World Cup,
and after not doing
so last time around,
this was the moment that,
really, I was most proud of.
What this World Cup
is gonna mean
to people, what it's gonna
mean to myself and my team,
which is everything.
And we're gonna give
it absolutely everything.
I wanna be a big leader
on the national team.
That's what I push for.
And every time I step
out on the field,
that's what I want
my teammates to see.
[Dramatic electric guitar]
- [Mark Pulisic:] We never expected any
of this to happen
as far as the level he
is, where he is right now.
But my wife and I knew
there was something
in him playing soccer.
It was almost unbearable
to see how driven he was.
- I think I've just
learned to be fearless.
Ever since I was, you know, super young,
playing against older kids. You know,
my dad taught me, taught me to
never be scared of anyone.
Go in, be confident, be
yourself, put in the work.
I think you can
accomplish anything,
and that's the way
I've always seen it.
- [Kristen Dania:] You ready?
- Yeah, man.
- Yeah?
- Let's do this thing.
Are you ready?
- Always.
[Funky mellow music]
Dude, you gotta do better than that.
- I was goin’ for the bank shot.
Watch. Ready?
Off the backboard.
Yes.
- That's what I like to see.
How do you keep that—
- Yeah.
- That mentality,
keep it through all these,
like, rough games?
- It's the competitive
spirit within me.
I just always wanna
win, no matter
what it is that I'm doing.
A lot of the top athletes will
have that same drive in them.
When something
that they're doing
isn't up to their
standards, they're
not gonna stop
training, not gonna
stop until they get
it right, and that's
how I've always been.
I truly am competitive
in everything that I do,
whether it's this, golf,
soccer, anything in the world.
- [Mark Pulisic:] Did he have a mindset of
an elite soccer player
from a young age?
I believe he did.
I think it's the
fearlessness to wanna be
put in uncomfortable positions.
And he was fearless
when he was 15 years old
and he had to make a
trip to Germany. And then
on his next move, to make a
step into the Premier League,
he accepted that challenge.
You know, you have to always wanna be
the best in everything you do,
whether it's every training
session, whatever you're
working on, as far as
what you need in your game
and putting that extra time in.
And he's willing to do that.
- [Dania:] You started becoming
a big fan of chess,
and I know that you
stream chess.
- I love chess.
It started a couple
years ago.
I think there is a
lot of just keeping
your mind sharp, and the way
that you have to think quickly.
And I also play a lot of, like, speed
chess. Like, three-minute games.
- Right.
- It's just, like, constantly
having to make decisions.
In some ways, it
does, like, calm me down.
After a tough day,
after a good day,
I can just come home
and go play some chess,
and it's just something
that I always enjoy doing.
- [Interviewer:] What would your advice
be to a young player
here, coping with
the mental pressures?
- Make sure you're always enjoying
the game, because that's
been a real big one for me.
You know, the second that you feel like
the game isn't fun anymore
and you're just playing
just to play and to please
other people, you're never gonna
reach the highest level.
So, you need to be
yourself. Enjoy the game.
Play because you love it, because
you have a passion for it,
and that's when I feel
like I'm at my best.
[Dramatic instrumentals]